[music playing]
NARRATOR: This rugged border
land between England and Wales
was the scene of many
battles over the centuries,
and it's a place with a rich
tradition of ghost stories.
Sal Masekela and historian
Davit Mills Daniels
are on the trail of England's
last known sin eater, a man
whose job was to
rid the dead of sin
and purge the land of ghosts.
Here we are at Richard
Munslow's tombstone.
This is his actual gravestone?
Yeah, this is it.
Wow.
So this is the final sin eater.
Look at that.
And there you see family
as children, four children.
Wow, this gives more of a
sense of him as a person.
Yeah, it does.
And you mentioned earlier that
usually it was poor people that
chose to practice this,
almost out of necessity,
not necessarily choice.
Munslow was a
farmer, a family man,
he seemed like he was
fairly successful.
Why would he choose this?
Yeah, it is a curious choice.
In particular,
someone like Munslow.
The basic motivation
Munslow seems to have had
is that his children
died quite suddenly.
NARRATOR: Three of Munslow's
young children took sick
and died in a
single week in 1817.
Davit believes Munslow may have
linked his personal tragedy
to the notion that unforgiven
sins were haunting the village.
This fear is about the souls
from the dead coming back
to haunt their own society.
What the senator was
doing was saving society
from the negative
consequences of sin.
So while they were
viewed somewhat as a pariah
within the community,
there is also
this sense of this is a value.
Right, yes.
Christ taken with
sins of the world,
but he has to die for
that to make it happen.
And so Munslow, he's
agreed to be damned.
Munslow seemed to have
viewed it as this act
of self-sacrificial love.
Personal tragedy
led Richard Munslow
to become the last sin eater.
Bereft by the loss
of his children,
he sacrificed his soul to save
the soul of his community.
He provided grieving families
with a sense of peace that he
himself would never know.
For someone already
so heavily burdened,
it was an incredibly noble act.
[music playing]